we are here to talk about the Dark Souls
3 the newest DLC releases when is that
actually attorneys out came out last
night okay nice so okay so but it did
leak last week yeah next box one you
said okay cool
so I guess like the main thing I want to
know is what is going on in this DLC is
it worth returning to Dark Souls 3 for
in this like slew of holiday releases
sure lore wise I can't help you too much
because I didn't play too much of the
soul stuff before but you're pretty much
going into our eundel if I'm saying that
right I mean I guess yeah something
similar yeah so it's like a snowy place
it's worth it in the sense that you know
anyone that plays Dark Souls probably
wants to play more Dark Souls right so
like for me like not having not played
Dark Souls for so long since you know
like release it's that whole like
learning how to play again and then like
being frustrated at first because it
does kind of what that old old hunters
did where the first couple areas you're
just getting swarmed by people instead
of like running into you're like one or
two people it's just like they're all
over the place and you're just like
frantically like dodging or rolling
around and then getting frustrated from
dying because like you kind of forgot
how to play and you don't have the
muscle memory but then ultimately being
rewarded once you figure it out again
like oh yeah this is why I like Dark
Souls because it's like really fluid and
you feel like satisfied and rewarded
when you actually like okay I learned
how he's gonna attack me I can dodge
like eight wolves now and kill them all
and it's fine but yeah I mean it's
basically if you play it you're gonna
want to play it I guess if you play Dark
Souls you're probably gonna play Dark
Souls 3 right for people who have played
all Dark Souls 3 might be I'm like a
second or third consecutive playthrough
and that is easy to get to the ashes of
aerion del DLC like how do like a
hundred years ago right is what's like
the level recommendation everyone so
from what I know is that if you're like
say you have a new game then you're just
like in your normal just first
playthrough assuming you haven't beat it
for some reason it's about 70 to 80 is
about the level you want to be at for
the content the DLC content and it's
actually really easy to get to you just
go to the Cathedral of the the you know
of the deep I think
just like I tried to screw that up but
like you know what I'm on board or the
know yes or the boreal valley neither so
where you fight the gang mob of priests
oh right the bottom floor right okay so
you take that bonfire and then the
moment you get to that bonfire there's
just like a dude that's kind of like to
the side that's kind of praying and just
talking to himself you let him go he was
all monologue then you talk to him he's
like touch this painting a piece of a
painting and he's like touch it come on
and then like no yeah yeah seriously so
then you know of course you're dumb and
you touch it and then it's just like
vacuums you into that world and that's
like the matrix or Alice in Wonderland
or the witcher 3 dlc do the same thing
yeah I don't know maybe that's like an
easy way to get people into DLC now is
to suck them into paintings or mirrors I
mean they did that in blood-borne -
right like the alien just like black
hole view into the new area oh yeah yes
at a certain point you don't care as
much how to get there is like actually
getting there yeah but how long does it
take you to finish so I haven't beat it
I'm on what I think is the last boss I'm
pretty sure like I'm almost positive it
took me about five hours I think to get
to last boss granted again playing like
really late at night and starting to get
frustrated I was trying to like rush
through parts and like that just ate up
like 30 to 40 minutes of just being
really stupid of you know you can't rush
through some of that stuff yeah knowing
Dark Souls this kid the blast boss could
take you anywhere from half an hour to
yeah two hours exactly so I would say
the dlc is probably like a six to eight
anywhere from like five day probably
actually rather depending on how good
you are how like level of you are maybe
you're over leveled you know or you're
just really good at the game so just
depends which is which is fair I think
it's 15 dollars for just this DLC or you
buy the season pass which would be both
DLCs for $24.99 okay watching the
gameplay right now it looks really open
I mean I remember old hunters is a
little more open than one born was
because blood-borne had the branching
paths as like you know the from software
games tend to do Dark Souls 3 the base
game as well was kind of there's some
open areas like when you get to the
woods at the beginning but it was still
also like specific paths you to take is
that kind of the case here the cool
thing about this area is most of it kind
of
we's with each other which is what Dark
Souls 3 did a good job of as well so
it's kind of like you go this way and
you're like oh I kind of loop back
around and in terms of the areas they
are for the most part more like open
areas like you see this area there's
what happens I don't want spoil too much
but it's early so it's fine you know
you're this is kind of like near the
start and you happen to see wolves and
some of them how old and then guess what
the whole family comes and you're kind
of surrounded and the the wolves the a I
actually like relatively smart in the
sense that as you're running away they
try to circle and they try to cut you
off so that you know that kind of pack
mentality I guess so that they kind of
like surround you um but it's intense
there's a couple of areas like this that
are like really open and there's just
like three four five enemies like
surrounding you so you have to kind of
like deal with that properly but of
course in true Dark Souls fashion there
are also very tight linear paths on like
mountains where there's two guys in
front of you and guess what you kind of
gotta like pull one away hopefully and
then kill him and then kill the next guy
and hope that you don't roll off the
ledge I rolled off the ledge or a
mountain at least two or three times not
but only because you're retired
no I there's a couple where I just
straight a botch because well it's it's
like that old Hunter's thing I hate to
keep kind of comparing it but they for
those weren't like completely familiar
oh there's the blood-borne DLC yes so
for some reason some of the the enemy
types in this like you think that
they're gonna be like running out of
stamina after like three sets of moves
and he just does like a fourth that
doesn't really make sense like oh yeah I
can finally attack you cuz you
straight-up did like a jumping smash
melee with that and follow up to melees
he's got to be available no turns out he
just doesn't care and he can keep
attacking so you gotta kind of get used
to that too but there aren't in my
opinion there aren't that many enemy
types and so like once you've figured
them out there's like a handful and once
you figure them out it's not so bad it's
more about managing fighting like
multiple like different enemies I guess
of the of the few that there are a lot
of wolves from what I'm seeing right now
yeah there's a like so if it's not just
wolves then it's like a Viking guy with
a wolf and then got to deal with both of
them
but yeah I kind of I really wish they
kind of just went down the path where
they combine both of them and made one
meaty
expansion instead of separating the dlcs
the first of two yeah this is the first
of two and I don't know that's just a
preference I guess I'd rather have more
at one time and wait longer than it
would like place on okay now I got away
to another like three months until like
the next one comes out but they did that
with Arsenal's too so so I really like
the old hunters because the bosses were
pretty tough I had a really hard time
with some of them and it actually kind
of felt like it was blood-borne still
but I feel like they did enough new
things and like the world itself little
more open and weird to like kind of you
know just find me buying that expansion
is this the case with this are you kind
of more lukewarm on this or your
impressions the the of the boss fights
I'm not gonna say how many yeah the boss
fights I've done they seem interesting
enough I feel like they're not
reinventing the wheel though they're not
so different you know then stuff you've
encountered over your Dark Souls career
or history of playing these games but
there's enough of a like twist that it's
like okay like this is kind of stressful
and I know that I haven't even gotten to
whatever phase that I need to in the
last boss I'm fighting and I know
there's some surprises there so I
haven't seen all that but in terms of
just the stuff I played it's worth $15 I
mean if you're getting five to six I
mean it's all relative right like how
much what's worth it to you kind of as a
consumer but I think if you're getting
five to six hours of a game that you
already enjoy playing and that's not
even me playing the PvP which they have
like 3v3 PvP and stuff like that now I
think it's worth it I think anyone that
but like I said anyone that plays Dark
Souls is probably playing the DLC right
so sure yeah I'm excited to play it I'm
hoping to find time between or like all
these releases coming up we have a bunch
still left before the holidays hit and
then we have a bunch more in the spring
but yeah five six hours seems like an
ideal kind of time I don't know that
like you said $15 seems like agreeable
but um that is ashes of aerion dell DLC
for Dark Souls 3 it's $15 but you can
buy it as a package for $25 with the
next unannounced DLC and that is out now
on ps4 Xbox one and PC